this is the image
gordon elliott has spent more than two
decades cultivating
that of a serial champion at 29 he was
the youngest ever grand national winning
trainer
and he's won the sport's biggest prize
twice more with tiger role
but this is the image he says he'll
spend his whole life
paying for it shows the irishman sat
ashride a dead horse
he says he sat down to take a phone call
this was just a one-off other said then
came this video
amateur jockey rob james who rode a
winner for elliot at the cheltenham
festival last year
also sat atop a dead horse he claims the
video was from 2016.
in a statement he said i'd just like to
apologize for my actions
which were wholly inappropriate and
disrespectful to a lovely five-year-old
mare
who unfortunately suffered a sudden
cardiac arrest
while at exercise earlier that morning
at newmarket home of british horse
racing they're reeling
often they find themselves defending
horse racing against welfare concerns
from outside
this feels like a betrayal from within
george has been in the sport all his
working life
i was disgusted um with what i saw
and never mind background or reasons or
anything
i i couldn't believe what i've seen
especially in somebody in such a high
position
that obviously runs a massive operation
and and should know better
the timing of these stories is
particularly uncomfortable
coming just two weeks before the start
of the cheltenham festival when horse
racing
is in the shop window they really don't
want to have to be contending with
stories like this
the irish horse racing regulatory board
is investigating gordon elliot and rob
james but the sports authorities are
keen to stress
that care like this is more indicative
of the industry
our job i think is to try and reassure
the british public that this isn't our
values this doesn't represent our
industry
we don't recognize this behavior at all
elliot's been dropped by his biggest
sponsor and deserted by one of his
biggest owners
his career hangs in the balance
horse racing is again searching for a
brighter horizon
martha kellner sky news new market